hi i'm greg jarbo i'm a member of the
market motive faculty
in this first section we're going to
talk about what content marketing is how
it works
and also explore why it works
it seems like a new buzzword to you it's
actually a term that's been around for
quite some time
it's just web search interest in content
marketing has tripled since 2010
according to google trends and that's
why a lot of people are now just
starting to get their arms around it
so what is content marketing
well according to rebecca lee a friend
of mine who wrote an article in
advertising age
content marketing is not just a
glorified way to say social media
marketing it's actually a little broader
concept so content marketing does
include social media and you can use
blogs facebook twitter
youtube vimeo linkedin google plus
pinterest foursquare instagram flickr
stumbleupon tumblr slideshare and quora
and you can put all of those together
in a content marketing program
and all of this content
can be optimized so it can be found in
search engines
as well as in social media
or in the usual places like your website
one of the ways to sort of conceptualize
this is the classic venn diagram
brian clark of copy blogger has put
together a really interesting white
paper called the business case for agile
content marketing in which she's created
this particular diagram that shows
search social and content and the
overlap of the three
is where he positions content marketing
and that may help you understand where
it fits it's sort of a little bit of
this a little bit of that but it also
shows you both the potential leverage
that you can get when you begin
combining these elements
but also the potential conflicts you may
encounter inside an organization who
says hey wait a second that's my job and
the real challenge to content marketing
is getting people who have been doing
their job independently headed off in
their own unique direction
to actually collaborate and coordinate
what they're doing
and leveraging each other's capabilities
to create something that's a little more
powerful